[Música]
porque mientras avanza la guerra en
ucrania y las tropas rusas bombardean
sin discreción occidente se sigue
enfocando en las sanciones económicas
contra moscú y a varios multimillonarios
de ese país conocidos también como los
oligarcas rusos estos castigos
financieros están dirigidos según las
autoridades de eeuu y reino unido- blend
europea a los empresarios del círculo
cercano del presidente de la emir putin
se trata de magnates con inversiones en
bienes raíces bancos equipos deportivos
y también propiedades en varias ciudades
alrededor de todo el mundo la estrategia
de estas sanciones es tratar de que
ellos puedan así presionar entonces al
mandatario ruso a que detenga su
invasión ucrania estos oligarcas se
empezaron a enriquecer tras la caída de
la unión soviética en 1991 además se han
vuelto millonarios por su cercanía y los
negocios que han hecho con el estado
para ello entonces quiero saludar en ese
momento a nuestro primer invitado de
javier de la nava profesor de cef udima
de macroeconomía y economía
internacional gracias a profesor javier
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24
quiero empezar preguntar es quiénes son
estos oligarcas rusos y por qué son tan
importantes para el kremlin
buenos días y muchísimas gracias por su
invitación
estos oligarcas yo creo que sería
conveniente primero definir la palabra
oligarca que viene de oligarquía es
decir el gobierno de unos pocos el
gobierno de unos pocos con gran potencia
económica social y al amparo de un poder
autocrático en este caso del presidente
putin decían muy bien en la introducción
que estos oligarcas empezaron a aparecer
después del desmembramiento de la unión
soviética pero eso son los oligarcas de
primera fase porque hay unos otros
oligarcas de segunda fase que
algunos pocos continuaron desde la
primera fase pero otros fueron nuevos a
raíz del ascenso del presidente putin
podemos establecer el sinónimo de
camarilla de gabinete próximo de
actuaciones en determinados ámbitos
ellos se benefician del régimen y el
régimen se beneficia de ellos no son
muchos y recientemente unas estadísticas
reflejaron que aquellas personas que
poseían un patrimonio superior en rusia
su superior a los diez mil millones de
dólares son más o menos 20.000 personas
estas 20 mil personas comparativamente
con las 150 o con los 150 millones de
habitantes de población de rusia vienen
a representar
0,02 por ciento pero su volumen en
cuanto a patrimonio económico se estima
alrededor de una tercera parte del
producto interior bruto de rusia
profesor estos estos millonarios
realmente tienen el poder de presión
para el gobierno del presidente ruso
vladimir putin
bueno
en una autocracia es muy difícil
establecer el límite de presión pero es
indudable de que si ellos se benefician
del régimen y el régimen de ellos el
hecho de la congelación de sus activos
de esos ingentes activos en el exterior
se estima que pudiera ser que en un
determinado momento se volvieran hacia
el régimen político de moscú y a decirle
oye estamos siendo claramente
perjudicados como consecuencia de la
medida de la invasión en ucrania pero si
hacemos un análisis de la historia
cuando en el año 2000 subió el
presidente putin y ya decía yo que
algunos oligarcas de la primera ola no
continuaron fue precisamente porque el
presidente putin estableció una serie de
requisitos una serie de obligaciones
muchos oligarcas de la primera ola
y no las asumieron y empezaron a caer en
desgracia otros aprovecharon la
situación y ocuparon los puestos que
iban dejándose libres o iba dando la
autorización para realizar determinadas
inversiones en sectores estratégicos
sobre todo en entidades financieras
energía energía y fertilizantes por
ejemplo twitter etcétera profesor
hablamos de las sanciones y el impacto
que tendrían en digamos en el gobierno
el presidente putin y en rusia pero qué
hay del impacto que tendrían del otro
lado países como reino unido canadá
países de la unión europea también
estados unidos que impusieron estas
sanciones
indudablemente también tendrían los
efectos lo que ocurre es que hay que
hacer el análisis coste-beneficio
ayer mismo hubo una nueva lista de
oligarcas rusos que dio el gobierno del
reino unido donde se establecía esta
congelación y estos requisitos e
indudablemente esas inversiones pueden
tener efectos sobre los países donde
están realizadas lo que ocurre que aquí
también no hay que olvidar que ya en el
año 2014 cuando se establecieron algunas
de estas sanciones que no se llevaron al
buen fin que se podían haber llevado
como consecuencia de este coste que
sufrían los propios países también en
este sentido si se dispusiera cosa que
no existe pero técnicamente es posible
de un régimen de inversiones y de
financiación es que en el exterior
pudiéramos asistir a grandes sorpresas
entre otras cosas porque muchas de estas
inversiones
se realizan a través de paraísos
fiscales y como bien se sabe
muchos de estos paraísos fiscales están
llamémosle entre comillas auspiciados o
por lo menos consentidos por esas
grandes potencias occidentales reino
unido con dilatar y que eeuu islas
vírgenes y holanda con la guayana
holandesa etcétera etcétera etcétera
luego tengamos y es verdad que ahora se
ha avanzado un poquito en ese sentido
asumiendo esas pérdidas los propios
países occidentales pero no teniendo más
remedio que realizar si queremos de
alguna manera manifestar que estamos en
contra de la invasión de ucrania por
parte de rusia pues profesor gracias por
su tiempo por su análisis para entender
un poco entonces quiénes son estos
llamados oligarcas rusos y el impacto no
que tendrían ellos dentro del círculo
del presidente vladimir putin si
realmente ellos pueden presionar para
que detenga esta invasión pero por lo
que usted decía pues en un auto que está
no se sabe y nada y seguro profesor
gracias es por estar con nosotros en
directo marca de france 24
muchas gracias a ustedes